you
you
hello everyone my name is Joel dart as
Jed said I come from a live and work in
indianapolis indiana in the united
states i work for a company called dino
where we do real-time classroom software
but tonight i'm going to talk about
people the good parts in javascript the
good parts Papa crockford as he is
affectionately called said the
JavaScript has an elegant core that
shines through despite his share of bad
parts he used the book to introduce a
new generation to this to the virtues of
this elegant core and to introduce a
tool called jslint where a tool designed
to shine a developer's attention
immediately on areas of the code that
either will cause problems or could in
time now entire talks have been devoted
to the good parts and the book's author
and jas lent but I wanted to highlight
what I find it be an interesting theme
in all of this one of the good parts
that we all know love is prototypal
inheritance here we're not able to only
define the features and functionality of
our objects but also to extend existing
objects by adding to their prototype
this has been used to extend the
language and to prototype out language
features and back port them into two
older browsers it also serves as the
basis for the very popular extends
pattern that we see in a lot of our
favorite frameworks here you can take
the properties and methods of one object
and put them directly on another object
allowing for very powerful and simple
means of multiple inheritance because
you can take something that exists
something that's complete in itself and
extend it to new heights this idea of
extension has has been embraced and
complemented by the web development
concept of progressive enhancement as
you know here we take we try to provide
a complete user experience in HTML alone
and then provide incremental
improvements to that UX
using CSS and finally JavaScript we take
something complete in itself and extend
it to new heights but the web
development community didn't create
progressive enhancement in fact in the
1920s film theorist and director Sergei
Eisenstein discussed a theory of montage
where you would take one complete scene
or or or image and a second complete
scene or image and through juxtaposition
Express a third new idea but even before
that the great minds of ancient Greece
such as Pythagoras discussed a system of
music based on 12 tones and tetra chords
but they were not content only to pluck
the liar so much so in fact they had is
a different system of musical notation
for when the music was set against the
text now I don't speak Greek but I'm
told that the I'm told that the music
itself and the the notation is let me
real quick change this
better it's not any better but it's okay
apologize for this not only that the
rhythms itself are inspired by the
language itself to the point of the
stresses in the natural stresses in the
language are found out the notation so
they took that it was very clear because
of this they intended to take something
complete in itself the text and extend
it to new heights my art project poetry
Jas means to take to continue in this
tradition of progressive enhancement
this human tradition of extension first
I take a text this is not
did I just break the projector
okay okay sorry about that once again
now we've got the full screen all right
so I take it I take the text such as
this one here that has its own theme and
tone control is power and I am in
control of my life this text itself is
comes from somebody who's very confident
I like to think of like an Alec Baldwin
Gordon Gekko salesy type of guy he's
worked very hard in his life and he's
accomplished a lot of things and
probably worked maybe a little harder
than those around him and because of
that he has it feels a deep sense of
pride about those outcomes but now that
I've got the text i extend it with
JavaScript semantics syntax and runtime
and here we can see the situation is
much more complicated than the narrator
originally thought now this has a happy
ending or at least a non crashing one as
happy and ending as boring code could be
but a seasoned JavaScript developer is
going to immediately recognize all the
implied Global's that are created and
the instability that adds to the program
additionally if you look a little closer
you can see one of the textbook examples
of unexpected results from type coercion
what looks to be a very simple and
obvious path forward has an unbelievable
number of hidden powers at work and this
brings me to my first bad part of people
narrow vision we especially in the
development community are very
intelligent people aware of a broad
range of subjects and especially and
we're also of even dangerous social
vices such as pride but for all our
wisdom we only know what we see just
like we wrote imply Global's before we
were taught in PI Global's so we're
arrogant we're overconfident but we are
not alone our vision is weak but it's
supplemented by those who see what we
cannot see now no one likes to be called
but the wounds of a friend can be
trusted even if it hurts your feelings
the second poem was actually my first
and probably still my favorite it reads
functionality zoom in a little bit
functionality variation one I know my
fate is undefined hate destroys file
betrayals to regret heart I pray the
vile betrayals are few but dare I while
I take continue healing Lord for this I
know and heart does break what vile
betrayals are my fate I pray the Lord my
soul to take I dare you not to take my
hate it's
it's a little emo it has a dark side to
it the the main narrator has a sense of
regret about themselves and who they are
and what they've done to people similar
to the nine inch nails song hurt or the
Johnny Cash cover if that's more your
scene but still there's a defiant
resistance to change the reasons aren't
clear but there's something that gets in
the way of making things right now when
we look at this at the poem I have a
little fun with the function turning
that into functionality and then VAR
into variation and then when we get back
to the text itself we can see I make a
literary allusion I pray the Lord my
soul to take from the children's nursery
rhyme now I lay me I bring this in for
some cultural critique but also to
introduce the concept of a savior but
this isn't a redemption story as the
code itself reveals now into this code
is basically broken up into due to two
parts the first part is exceptionally
boring just establishing variables and
walking through the code but the second
part actually something interesting
happens we get ourselves into an
infinite loop one of the worst possible
error state so we can be in this has
additional interest because of the way
that the the runtime interacts with the
text below it as we're in this infinite
loop were stuck constantly approaching
healing and never able to achieve it so
why do we get in this infinite loop well
because of the truthiness of I take I is
just a config object passed into the
function but dare and which is called at
the bottom but dere is basically just
passes through the properties from the
my variable which is defined up at the
top as a simple object literal with to
own properties fate which is undefined
and hate which is a string
choice so we're in this infinite loop
because of the existence of the own
property hate but what's interesting
about that own property is that its
shadows the clean prototype underneath
it if we were to have a simple delete
statement before calling but there then
the prototype would shine through and we
would never be in this situation but the
program is written there is no delete
and we're stuck looping forever but
looking back to this relationship
there's something about this
relationship between owned properties
and prototypes the prototype is the
Platonic ideal and the own properties as
the things that get in the way of who we
can really be the things we have to let
go this next poem is called art and fear
it goes when it happens when it happens
who sees what this program does all
together now it does nothing we see we
can't help but see the infinite
recursion and the payroll to any person
who dares call this code but the reality
the reality of it is as ominous as this
code is it's harmless the program is
written
imposter syndrome is surprisingly
rampant in our community if they only
knew how little I know they'd fire me on
the spot right but um this this is
titled art and fear because of a book
with the same title about the troubles
and identity issues in the art community
it's very useful for an artist but I
recommend it for programmers as well in
the book one of the interesting
observations the author is that how odd
it is that an artist can make art and
still doubt themselves as an artist if
we were to watch this code in Internet
Explorer 10 and I believe some other
engines as well we see another
interesting output because ie10 has an
interesting runtime complement I'm
optimization called delayed compilation
whereby programs aren't even functions
aren't even compiled until their first
indication which means not only does
this this code not matter enough to
devote execution cycles it doesn't even
turn it into machine code what an
amazing optimization to see things for
how they really are but still with with
the truth out there why is it that we
let fear get be one of the things that
prevents us from being who we can really
be and the problem with impostor
syndrome is that to beat it you have to
convince yourself that you're wrong
which brings me to my next bad part
we're obstinate we don't like change
even when we know know what to do is not
only the bullheaded rope from the first
poem variation one sometimes it's the
more vulnerable impostor syndrome but in
either case we don't like to make
changes on our own we need others to
encourage us and to hold us accountable
by all means be the change you want to
see in the world but think back the
reading the main reason why people
volunteer is because someone asked them
to
that's right forgot to zoom in all right
this last this last work that I wanted
to share with you is the children's
story that I wrote named little coder
when I decided I wanted to write a
children's story I knew it needed to be
exciting so I decided to highlight the
most heroic of JavaScript language
features hoisting honestly when you see
some code and reading through it like oh
no this isn't going to work and then it
totally does because of hoisting it to
me at least it feels like it swoops in
there at the last moment to save the day
that's excitement that's adventure
that's worsening so here's the poem yes
hoisting for all now the poem itself is
wrapped in and they feel like most of
our programs are we're here I'm able to
pass a special message to my daughter
disguised as the dedication / the end
structure and then after that it's built
in three paragraphs and a dangerous
forest of hoisted variables and I played
with the white space a little to give it
this uneasy cramped feeling as you're
walking down the path so with that it
reads little coder on your way much
advice will people say for performance
team work or to make more clear don't
let your imagination gray and all this
advice is truly good though it's often
misunderstood for all that comes out of
love deserves respect as it should but
you must fight avoid a yawn statements
to build function on must state the
truth that lives in you before the you
in here is gone so when we take a look
at the Hat the poem itself first thing I
do is make a cultural illusion up here
in for performance where you can see the
very first piece of JavaScript
performance advice you ever received to
cash your your length in your variables
or in a for loop then additionally later
on there's some word painting with you
and here and then above that comes out
of love as love kind of bubbles out of
itself but other than that and the
hoisting this is
really much more about the message
itself which is good because I feel that
it's kind of an important message in the
poem it's her in the in the story it's
basically some advice you would give up
to a programmer who's starting out to
that there's going to be all this advice
and you need to take it and respect it
but in the end you have to choose your
own path but in this I believe that
there's a relatively controversial
challenge a judgement went if you will
to take all the advice you're given and
try to find the author's love in it see
you can call jslint paternalistic and it
is paternalistic but he wrote it because
he honestly wanted to help people avoid
the pain from those errors and the same
thing goes for those who rail against
paternalism they want people to be able
to make their own choices and their own
trade-offs and to not lose the power in
the language amber people feel that a
really curated happy path is going to
make web development easier micro
library feel that choice is what makes
web development easier they're putting
their opinions out there because they
care so respect right you can find your
own path and still respect those who
pointed you in a different direction but
these different directions should also
be celebrated diversity of thought and
newly explored avenues have stretched
the boundaries of humanity we create and
we reinvent and we disagree but the
pursuit benefits us all the commons we
enjoy today are built off of those
creating the commons before us the other
really interesting and defining feature
of hoisting is the inherent rising
motion we have so many heroes in the
JavaScript community some provide ideas
others energy and time organizing others
code but we all rise with their tide so
my question to you is do you see the
good parts java script was written with
a really tiny standard library no string
interpolation or extends or or contains
no array insert or map and as we've
discussed we ourselves are also pretty
limited lacking in vision in
in humility and I'm pretty sure we all
have our own special missing radix
feature so where are these good parts
well despite its standard library java
script was written to be incredibly
extensible to allow the community to
fill in the rest and from that the
communities extended it to Heights I
don't think any of us had dreamed and
one of the defining features of our
primate tribe is the fact that we have
tribes we've seen not only that there is
safety in numbers but in our language
our art all our best ideas from
democracy to open source to the Internet
they all seem to echo the redemption
story that I am NOT the best person I
can be on my best day but when I'm
extended and so if I have one parting
challenge for you it's to always be
looking for the good parts in others
allow yourself to be hoisted by the best
in your neighbors and try to mix end
when you can when I look back at what
what attracted me to this language I
always joke that it was the unicorns and
pirates that sold me but here is a
community thank
you
you